Prior to medicine, I worked for five years in business.
And while it was interesting and I was advancing
in my career, it just seemed like a job.
And what I'm finding now as I advance
in my emergency medicine career is
that it is not just a job,
it's something I get to do every day
that is a privilege,
and I get to serve my community
and people within our community
who don't always have access to care.
I grew up in Atlanta, a little bit north of the city,
and my parents both came here
from India in the mid-60s.
When I got to college, I sort of started down
the path of finance and economics and
really thought that someday I might
actually become a corporate attorney.
So when I said, "I think I'm actually
going to pursue medicine,"
they were pretty surprised.
I met my husband as an undergraduate here at Emory.
We've been married seventeen years.
We have two lovely girls,
one's four and a half, the other's two.
I work clinically here at Grady, which is a wonderful
experience and very personally satisfying for me.
I spend a certain part of my time every week working
at the School of Medicine as a small group advisor,
and so you develop this very wonderful
relationship with these students,
and not only do you get to spend time with them
teaching, but you also learn a lot about yourself.
Something that I'm really passionate about is some
work that I do around screening patients for HIV.
When I was in medical school
I actually took a year off
and lived in India for a year.
And during that time I had the opportunity
to work with a physician in India who had
been taking care of HIV patients for over 20 years.
In 2006 the CDC actually recommended
that all patients in acute-care settings
that are age 13 to 64 be tested for HIV
regardless of their chief complaint or risk profile.
And then I had the opportunity to try and make routine
HIV testing part of what we do every day at Grady.
It just seemed like it was the perfect fit for me.
I work with a great team of individuals.
We're currently working at 13 sites at Grady,
in the emergency department, in the walk-in clinic,
all the primary care clinics
in our six neighborhood clinics.
The majority of them are now doing routine screenings.
I'm proud to say that we have tested
over 80,000 patients and identified
over 500 new HIV diagnoses.
One of the reasons I think
routine testing is so important is because
it de-stigmatizes the idea of getting an HIV test.
It's just really a matter of treating patients
as if they're your family.
And to let them know that
that's how you approach their care.